take upon mistake
you
you
all right welcome everybody I was not
planning to stream today but it looks
like we are indeed going to war and as
you can see I've got my contacts out
I've got my gym shirt on this was not I
mean we had a sense that this was coming
I didn't think it would necessarily be
tonight but it appears that this is
getting going
Iran has hit a US base with missiles
there is a lot to discuss and we're
going to be here doing it let's start
with the news there has been a missile
attack on US bases in Iraq this is being
announced as revenge for the killing of
the Iranian codes leader Kasim sulemani
let's look at the latest news this is an
article from The Jerusalem Post updated
just fifteen minutes ago Iran launched
more than a dozen ballistic missiles and
targeted US bases in Iraq on Tuesday
night in retaliation for the killing of
Qasem Soleimani last week the Pentagon
says the missiles were launched from
Iran the Pentagon confirmed that more
than a dozen ballistic missiles had been
fired at a number of US military bases
in Iraq including the al Asad airbase
which hosts both Iraqi and US soldiers
US officials confirmed that a missile
attack had taken place and said that
President Donald Trump was being briefed
on the situation that's the guy we want
in charge right the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard Corps confirmed that
carried out the missile attack against
US forces as part of an operation named
martyr soleimani
this is not god this is this is already
horrible and said in a statement that it
was the first step of their retaliation
for the killing of the Koontz Force
Commander on Friday the IRGC statement
claimed that dozens of missiles had been
fired at Al Asad airbase
Iranian media reported that a second
wave of missiles was being fired at us
targets in Iraq after the initial attack
quote from White House spokeswoman
Stephane Grisham we are aware of the
reports of attacks on US facilities in
Iraq the president has been briefed than
is monitoring the situation closely in
consulting with his national security
team House Speaker Nancy Pelosi was
briefed on the attack during a
with Democrats on Tuesday according to
CNN rep Debbie danjel stated that Pelosi
told members of the meeting pray it's
happening folks saying that Trump may be
going live soon let's let's keep me
posted on on where that may happen
because of course we are going to want
to carry that we have live ABC news
coverage that is taking place here this
is breaking news and it the this it's
this is so Trump is not going live CNN
confirms okay Trump will not be
addressing tonight maybe that is good
news as people are saying I am I am star
T you know I remember not long after I
moved to the United States that the
first Iraq war took place and I remember
watching it on television and I remember
the rockets and I remember it all under
George HW Bush and then when I was in
high school I remember similar things
with the second war in Iraq and I
remember shocked and on it being
reported almost gleefully in some cases
by corporate media like a sporting event
- in a sense and it seems as though
things are going very very much in the
same direction questions already about
are there deaths from the bombings we
don't know yet certainly there are going
to be I mean this this this is going to
lead to some deaths if it continues to
escalate let's look at this article from
The Associated Press and see if it gives
us any new information
Iran struck back we know that two Iraqi
bases housing US troops and warning the
u.s. not to retaliate Iran only
initially acknowledged targeting one
base no immediate word on injuries we
already know Iranian state TV says this
is revenge for the killing of Qasem
Soleimani the Iran Revolutionary Guard
is warning about retaliation we are
warning all American allies who gave
their bases to its terrorist army that
any territory that is the starting point
of aggressive acts against Iran will be
targeted
we already talked about martyr Soleimani
a spokesperson for the Norwegian Armed
Forces told AP in a phone interview that
about 70 Norwegian troops were on the
airbase no injuries reported thus far
this is going to get extremely ugly and
remember that we heard from wasn't Mike
Pompeo that this is all just noise well
when the deaths start we'll see if they
can still call it just noise we have
been told that this is going to be very
simple we were told that this was going
to be easily taken care of by alpha male
Donald Trump and it is going to be the
opposite of all of these things and it
is it's just depressing I mean what else
is there to say this is this is
potentially the start of another you
know the United States has a long
history of fighting politically
motivated wars there's a very long list
of them let's look at the Department of
Defense Twitter as people are suggesting
while we talk about this Department of
Defense okay let's see what the
Department of the defense is saying here
let's start at the beginning so it's a
four tweet series let's take a look at
it this this is I'm struggling to keep
up with this as much as everybody is so
let's let's take a look at everything
together Department of Defense has sent
a four tweet series the following
statement is attributed to chief pent
Spock's chief Pentagon spokesman at
approximately 5:30 Eastern on January
7th Iran launched at least a dozen
ballistic missiles against US military
and coalition forces in Iraq it is clear
that these missiles were launched from
Iran and targeted at least to Iraqi
military bases hosting US military and
coalition personnel at Al Asad and Erbil
we are working on initial battle damage
assessments this this is this is
starting to look more and more like a
war it's sounding more like a war in
recent days and in response to Iranian
threats and actions of the Department of
Defense has taken all appropriate
measures to safeguard our personnel and
partners these bases have been on high
alert due to indications that the
Iranian regime planned to attack our
forces and interest in the region as we
evaluate the situation in our response
we will take all necessary measures to
protect and defend US personnel partners
and allies in the region due to the
dynamic nature of the situation we will
continue to provide updates as they
become available the latest from ABC
news still nothing still nothing we are
going to keep an eye on this Twitter
account for sure and this is looking
extraordinarily ugly this is looking
extraordinarily ugly let me see I had a
few other updated articles that I wanted
to so there is another let me see if
this is the same article it seems to be
oh I see The Jerusalem Post has updated
this let's refresh let's take a look at
this video and see what's going on feels
like 2003 all over again
this is because Trump is impeached guys
this is that this is the worst of this
is the worst of the worst of politically
motivated warfare I'm starting to get
some messages via super chat over on
youtube as well as on on Twitch let's
start looking at what folks are sending
in awesome gaming says doubt Dow Jones
futures are down 360 you know I don't I
don't actually see that Oh 17 minutes
ago maybe that's I see it's not being
reflected live not that the stock market
is the main thing here but the reason
this is interesting is that so far even
with the killing of Soleimani you didn't
see the markets crash which was a sign
that it wasn't yet necessarily
escalating now we see US stock futures
slumped along with Asian equities
futures on the S&P 500 dropped more than
1% 1% on the Dow is is close to 300
right yeah so that makes sense
futures declined 1.3 percent of 10:20
a.m. in Tokyo tomorrow tomorrow is going
to be brutal I mean listen that that is
that is so secondary at this point but
it is absolutely a sign that this is
going to get increasingly ugly trendy as
dabber says is it a good time to golf or
vacation at a Trump business I would
obviously be staying away from from
those anyway but I would say no Ryan
Henry Dean says via super chat if Trump
says no more attacks on the US and stops
now I actually think his strategy might
work Iran would not do more they got
their revenge we avoid war but Trump
still looks strong maybe Trump is not
going to believe himself to be strong if
the last word is Iran bombing two of our
bases I mean that that's listen we know
Trump guys if the last word is they bomb
two of our bases Donald Trump is not
going to be satisfied by that no doubt
I can't believe we have to do this at
the serious time but I do have to to ban
a few people because the anti-semitism
is running rampant listen that this is
not about me being Jewish guys I hate to
break it to you
moderators in the chat please do help me
and let's see here I am gonna do my best
to keep up with banning all the stuff
okay people are asking about phone calls
I don't know maybe maybe we will maybe
we will do phone calls I have no idea
what is going to happen tonight we are
keeping an eye on the Department of
Defense which has been sending a number
of tweets I I will thank members I mean
listen we're I don't know how long this
is going to be if you want to support
what we're doing this may be an
all-night stream I will thank folks and
I want to thank Michael Michael Batista
who has signed up at join pakman.com
thanks Michael very much appreciate that
let me see the questions people have
over on Twitch l 1491 subscribed and
says thanks for keeping us in the know
my pleasure
mio fard subscribed with prime Moondog
22 subscribed with prime miltonic
subscribed with prime thanks very much
Lisa MW says via super chat on YouTube
thanks for hopping on glasses and all to
hang out and let us know what's going on
I appreciate how you do that whenever
stuff is going on yeah this this may be
a very very long night we genuinely
don't know what to expect and let me see
if I can pull up a Google News feed and
we can see what else is coming in if
people have specific bits of news we
should be looking at I'm glad to do it
things are happening so quickly that it
is very very difficult to keep up but
there is there is a lot going on and we
listen if by tomorrow morning we were in
in committed to more of an escalation
militarily with Iran I would not be at
all surprised if a few days go on go by
without much else happening that would
also not be
not not be a huge shock it's very
unpredictable what it is that we are
going to see happen here let's take a
listen to a little bit of ABC's coverage
and see what's going on US troops are
headed to the Middle East as part of
this escalating crisis with Iran and
what more do we know about US presence
at that base and whether or not there
had been any movement beforehand based
on these threats from Iran that there
would be retaliation yeah that's right
David we believe that the
three-and-a-half thousand extra troops
were flown into the region this is
primarily in gray weight to try and
bolster US defensive positions we right
iron asset is one of the key bases in
fact when the President ordered the
withdrawal of some troops from Syria ein
Assad was one of the places where some
of those troops went so there a
significant number of them this is a key
airbase in western Iraq as you say the
Iranians have been very clear that
they've targeted it US officials have
confirmed to ABC News that an airbase or
that a base has been has come under
attack they also said that a bill where
we are in northern Iraq listen this this
this has every indication that it is
about to get absolutely and completely
insane we have if you're just joining us
breaking news
there have been ballistic missiles fired
from inside Iran at two at least two
bases and now it's starting to seem as
though maybe a third base in Iraq maybe
has been attacked we're trying to keep
up with the information as best we can
let me thank some other people and
answer some questions some body says via
super chat this is the best time for
Trump fans to join the army put your
money where your mouth is I mean listen
that's not a crazy reaction to have
right if there are people who genuinely
think this is a good idea go and sign up
the way people did after 9/11 waiting to
fade says what books would you recommend
to learn more about the Iraq war
I'm actually not sure I don't I don't
have any any Iraq war books in mind and
earu says what's your take on the
relationship between Iran Russia and
China in terms of the response by Iran
going to address that on the program
tomorrow I'm still
sort of hammering out my thoughts on
that and and that is a there there are a
number of complexities there to consider
thanks to Cody Crossman for signing up
at join pakman.com as well as Danielle
Coleman and Jason Terry
I really appreciate everybody's support
as you can probably tell I'm in gym
clothes and have taken my contacts out
for the day and was getting ready to
have a very early evening and we we may
be going to war here so we are covering
what's going on I do want to hear from
you we're live on YouTube we are live on
Twitch let me thank atonium on Twitch as
well as chef gyro and Nexus
one-one-one-one
for signing up with twitch Prime as well
as Jethro parsons it is what must be
eight hours later right so it must be
about nearly 5:00 a.m. let me see
current time in Baghdad
this is 455 a.m. this is you know when I
think back to the first Iraq war when I
was like eight years old when I think
back to the second Iraq war this is
typically the time where it gets going
where we learn about it it's often
between 3:00 and 5:00 a.m. the the
darkest point of the night when you
start to see the hostilities and they
become very late nights and this is did
this this for me is feeling once again
like one of those I'm seeing messages
from folks saying that Iran is starting
another round of attacks we did that but
I'm not seeing any any other information
let's see if the Jerusalem Post which
has been keeping us updated this has
been updated again let's see if there's
any additional information that would be
relevant Iranian media reported a second
wave of missiles but I think that that
is not new the stock market information
has been updated oil prices rose this is
this is the exact predictable trajectory
that we would be anticipating here and
we will see if Google News
updates here as well the latest that we
are seeing is from CNN 14 minutes ago
let's take a look still two bases are
the reports two bases are the reports
yeah we've got that you know this is
really we've got a look at Hillary
Clinton's emails I mean listen if we
don't figure out what happened with
those emails yeah it's obviously that's
insane
obviously that is absolutely and
completely insane let me read a few more
Super chats because I do see them coming
in dunkey gamer says this was
predictable but with Trump we really
don't know if it's stoppable that is the
fear that is the fear from a lot of
people ryan henry dean says I feel Trump
could stop and look strong no US
casualties yet he could say that the
response from Iran was weakened that he
doesn't want war it would be a political
win he would appear wise yet people that
are saying this could be it so here's
the idea when we're trying to think
about how much this could escalate
there's the idea that Trump could say we
got soleimani they didn't kill anybody
and just sent some missiles at some
bombs Trump can be the big person and
just say we're not going to go any
further does that match what we know
about Trump's personality no there is no
way in my mind that I envisioned that
that is what is going to go on because
Trump temperamentally could not possibly
tolerate that so I can't imagine that
that's what we're going to see drew was
me sends a $50 super chap thanks for
putting up with the irrelevant comments
glasses Jewish gay etcetera I don't care
you have a great honest independent news
voice thanks I am Jewish I'm not gay
I do wear glasses or contacts when I'm
on the show I'm typically wearing
contacts yeah listen this this is this
is a this is starting to feel like one
of those moments where we will all
remember where we were and what we were
doing when we found out that war with
Iran started and I hope that that's not
the case but it is increasingly it is
increasingly looking like that and that
is extremely scary I'm seeing folks say
that there has been an updated
that Newsweek has news about this okay
let's take a look at the Newsweek
Newsweek Twitter and see what is the
latest there okay ace of spades geez ah
here we go
senior Defense Department official tells
Newsweek zero casualties at the moment
news came in at 8:28 p.m. Eastern Time
okay so that's 30 minute old news would
they even you know the first responder
says I wouldn't trust anyone from this
administration I I don't know that I
believe anything that they say at this
point in time and it may not there may
be casualties there may not it's going
to take a while for us to figure that
out let me say thank you to Duggar Jones
Duggar Jones just signed up at join
pakman.com and his new member number 5
of the evening I really appreciate
everybody's support this was an
impromptu stream it may go a while
depending on the interest level and what
what news breaks ABC News for now
everybody's trying to figure out what's
going on they are just replaying Martha
Raddatz his interview with the Iranian
FM is that finance minister foreign
minister which took place shortly before
the Iran strike CNN has the 22 P font
now let's see what's happening on Iran
attacks a rocky bases how bases housing
American troops Pentagon says Iran
launched more than a dozen ballistic
missiles so we have done there's a lot
of repeat stuff we know it was about a
dozen missiles and two bases so far and
we're waiting to see what what other
information comes forward reuters has a
new video can someone tell me if that's
can I find it on the Reuters Twitter do
I need to go on Reuters YouTube let's
look at Reuters live blog oh this may be
useful to us yes
explosions as Rockets land at what is
believed to be I in Al Asad airbase Iran
press via Reuters okay let's take a look
at the video lesson does anybody in the
chat support this
I mean I'm curious that this seems so
obviously misguided this seems so
obviously politically motivated this
seems so obviously Donald Trump fighting
political battles anti impeachment is
there anyone watching on either twitch
or YouTube that likes what is going on
and that says I want this let's go let's
go you know let's get it let's get Iran
Wow very little I don't know I mean a
couple people and it looks like maybe
they're kidding only idiots and trolls
want this it's not a joke I mean I'm
genuinely curious whether there are
people who believe that this is a
worthwhile battle to be fighting we have
been fighting Iran for decades that's
true Wow okay / overwhelming response
overwhelming response from people in the
chat trendiest dabbers says via super
chat it is so ironic that obama taunted
trump at the press corps dinner over the
birther issue made the deal with iran
now Trump has undone the deal in
response to the troll it's as if it's
Obama's fault not sure I understand you
trendy this is Agel says don't trust the
tweet saying no casualties this is
standard media blackout response
immediately following attacks we did the
same thing when it was Iraq very good
point that's a very good point David
Seoul says maybe the military needs to
set up recruitment tables at Trump rally
going forward listen it even my chat
which very often has folks from the
right I nobody is saying that this is
this is a good idea let's see if we have
anything tweeted from Donald Trump still
nothing his last tweet is still from
from six hours ago
Joseph van Scoy says alia I act that
esthe we have unfortunately reached the
point of no return mark mark my words
this will backfire in November it seems
sort of inappropriate when we may be
about to start seeing casualties in this
pointless political war meant to
distract from Donald Trump's impeachment
it seems something seems wrong with
starting to talk about the political
implications but the question of whether
this will backfire in November is a
perfectly reasonable one to be asking
and I don't know the answer
f majors biggest fan says I don't
support anything that could lead to war
why does Trump choose war over peace he
has to know that war may kill innocent
people I hope I'll stay safe you know I
was texting with my little sister today
and she was she was born after the Iraq
war the second Iraq war started and she
was saying do you think we could be
bombed here in the United States and my
answer was I don't think so I don't
think that that would happen but the
fact that we can comfortably or
relatively comfortably say that suggests
a huge level of privilege in the sense
that Donald Trump can play this like a
video game for political purposes
because it is so unlikely that the war
would ever come to the u.s. for
geographical recent reasons for reasons
of political power and for all of the
other reasons that that many of you know
killer of syrial says some individuals
investing in cryptocurrency might be in
support of the war I'm actually curious
I'm gonna look at my coin base account
has crypto spiked Wow
cryptocurrency has gone crazy in the
last few hours that is actually an
extraordinarily interesting side story
to this Wow I am I'm amazed at what we
are seeing here but in the last what was
it I guess since in the last few hours
cryptocurrency has really popped and
that it I don't know why I guess the
reason that would be is concerns about
economies Western economies and the
currencies that are connected to those
economies and in the same way that thou
futures are down hundreds of points
maybe people are seeing crypto as some
kind of safe haven or something like
that I don't know
Edgard Torres says this wouldn't be
happening without the Iraq war anyone
who voted for it should be immediately
disqualified
Joseph Orlando says it's a terrible idea
but what do you think if people died on
our side do we just let that go that
that's not even really the question to
be had right now that that's that's not
the immediately the the immediate
question is what is the next step here
Ryan or wiki how do you think it will
affect the US media if and when our
allies as well as Iran and others tell
us to get out of the Middle East and
they abandon us
well the listen the corporate media that
basically casually sort of cheer leads
American military intervention with very
little critical analysis potentially
will end up between a rock and a hard
place if that takes place ali reza
Mariga semi says putin had traveled to
syria to meet assad hours before the
attack then went to Turkey to meet air
Dewan in an unplanned manner manner what
is your idea on that first I'm hearing
of it and I I don't know anything about
it yet let me say thanks to a few other
new members Alan skarupa has signed up
at join pakman.com Jo curse AK has
signed up at join pakman.com Lori
Hamilton and Keith West
Kevin Westermann have also signed up at
join Pakman
thanks so much that is 9 new members
this evening I don't know how long we
are going to be streaming but there is a
lot happening and we are all just here
together trying to figure out what it is
that is going on let me say thanks to
some folks over on Twitch I don't want
to forget about you guys want to see
what's on your mind
thanks to after-dark for the
subscription Scriv nav Oh a tank where
Ray Charles SC for deaf leprechaun and
Michigan Mike thanks to all of you guys
if you have any questions for me feel
free to include them with your twitch
prime message a lot of YouTube super
chats coming in and I will keep going
through them as we await more
information here about what is taking
place if you're just joining us this may
be the beginning of the United States
Iran war jean-guy says an Iranian on
thom hartmann show said iran was so
close to overthrowing the ayatollah they
are very unpopular yet this united them
such backfire i've been actually talking
to some Iranian friends about that and
they agree completely thanks to Steven
Lindsay Satterfield for the super chat
Terry James says the only silver lining
is it may hurt Trump in November I don't
know the answer to that because it is a
very common meme in American politics to
say we don't want to change horses
midstream when we are in the middle of a
military conflict and I would not
consider it a foregone conclusion that
this hurts Trump in November I wish we
could happens maker says hey-ho out of
switzerland just started my night shift
pause pretty crazy honestly to kind of
have a firstrow seat on those
information due to my night shift but
still thank you David for your efforts
glad to be doing this for everybody
although it is absolutely sickening that
this is going on
Ryan Henry Dean says I would support
this if it stopped now I agree with
deterrence and if it was any other
president I might trust the Soleimani
intelligence
a user whose name is in Cyrillic sends I
believe 100 is it Russian rubles saying
what's wrong with humanity my question
as well
knowledge gizmo says the sad thing is by
the time countless us lives are lost it
won't even matter why a war started
Trump and his war mongers are counting
on that it reminds me of it reminds me
of the book the forever war by Joe
Haldeman one of my favorite sci-fi
authors Joe Haldeman 'he's Forever War
was sort of an analogy to Vietnam it is
one of my favorite sort of it's not
really a space opera but it's sort of as
it's one of my favorite space opera type
books and one of the things about that
book is because of the time-travel
component and something called time
dilation it doesn't the details don't
matter but the point is there are people
who are fighting the war who will never
make it back because of the time it
takes to travel I'm explaining this so
terribly the point is everybody because
if time travel forgets why the war even
started what it would mean to win it and
what the battle lines are that's the
point and it is very much a reminiscent
of what we are talking about here as
knowledge gizmo points out winter
solstice says David is there any way we
can skip paying taxes I feel horrible
that almost 60% of my tax money goes to
war no more Wars so listen this is
actually an interesting point - an
interesting moment to bring this up I
want to talk about strategic defaults
and and as a protest tactic because it's
really important thanks to Tia Maria
Smith for signing up at join pakman.com
and Vincent Cardin Asst I really
appreciate you guys signing up eleven
people have signed up so here's the deal
let's let's see how to cash this I've
talked before about protest activism
tactics that are fine but they're not
really going to achieve the change that
that we want right so like signing
petitions
great do it calling your members of
Congress absolutely do it but if we
really want to achieve systemic change
in this country we've likely likely are
going to need truly you know people
strategic call-outs from work to [ __ ]
industry mass rallies at urban centers
strategic defaults to [ __ ] the
financial system and this is one where
if you so the way that would work is if
there was a coordinated effort for
everybody to stop paying their mortgages
right within a month you would [ __ ]
the financial industries you would you
would in many ways [ __ ] government
and it would be extraordinarily
impactful but the whole point of the
system is to throw people enough of a
bone that they don't do that but to also
prevent them from having a good enough
situation where they can afford to go
and do that type of activism remember
that most people pay taxes less so like
I'm self-employed I'm on a salary but I
run the business so I kind of choose
when to pay my taxes I pay what are
called estimated taxes most people are
paying their taxes through their
employers so it would really be up to
the employer to say we are going to stop
paying taxes we're gonna stop sending in
tax money and of course if everybody
does it the government would be
completely overwhelmed and crippled and
people are pointing out the bank can
just print money if they if you print
money to this degree if all tax revenue
stops that's very different than saying
we're gonna print a little bit of money
to fund healthcare we're talking about a
completely different scale maybe that
would be the type of activism that gets
the military-industrial status quo to be
rethought remember that's a status quo
which Democrats are not quite but close
to as complicit in as as Republicans
anyway yeah that that's an issue I've
talked about many many times before and
we will likely talk about it again let
me see what other super chats are coming
in here Joseph
van Scoy says war with Iran will mean
thousands of Americans dead and as
always the poor will fight it and the
rich will profit from it that's the way
it works that is literal
the that is literally the American Way
no question about it let's do a check of
what's going on we'll see if there are
any Google News updates here still two
bases reportedly targeted let's take a
look at whether Donald Trump has sent
out any more tweets today no he has not
let's look at the Department of Defense
Twitter oh I misspelled it Department of
Defense there we go see if they have any
updates
none as of yet and then let's check
check Reuters to see if they have
anything new oh they have this live blog
okay so the last update was 8:10 p.m.
let's see if there's anything new we're
all trying to figure out what's going on
just this video and then let's see if
CNN has any updates as well nothing new
as of yet reports are that Donald Trump
will not be speaking tonight people in
the chat can confirm whether that is or
is not the case let me say thanks to a
few other folks who are supporting the
stream on Twitch
thanks to clerics storm for subscribing
with twitch prime alluring Lord says
what are the chances of this going
further than just us and Iran with China
and Russia allied with Iran the chances
are nonzero and I'm going to address
that tomorrow for sure
Comstock rocker says with their twitch
prime sub is there a chance Congress
will rein this in I wish I could say yes
but it but I think the answer is no I
think that the answer is probably no on
that unfortunately let me say thanks to
Trevor Dell Kerr for signing up at join
pakman.com and Ryan Harrison Patrick
deep-ass as well really appreciate the
support let's maybe let some
okay the super chats are coming in fast
and furious but I do want to get let's
just listen a little bit this is all
earlier so we're not actually seeing
anything live is there a better actual
livestream that
could pick up here I check to see if PBS
went live but they didn't I'm glad to
switch to maybe a more updated live
stream so to speak because this does not
seem to be giving us what we want
CBS n let's see what they've got going
on okay yeah let's take a look at that
see what they're reporting at this point
firmly with Iran and not one of its
proxies of its militias and not one of
its allies in Syria now if we just kind
of go back a little bit by the way it's
sort of disgusting that longtime Fox
News flunky Catherine Herridge is the
one giving us the news on this I'd much
rather hear it from somebody else but
regardless let's see what they are
reporting a horrible terrorist he was
someone who was responsible kind of
pioneered the idea of ieg attacks and
suicide attacks against our military
personnel in Iraq and just as an
anecdote for you and folks at home one
of my contacts was explaining to me that
there was a lot of sort of sweet irony
in the fact that general Soleimani was
killed on that route coming out of
Baghdad
sweet irony how disgusting give me a
break
okay a Dave Rubin has showed up in the
chat and wants to know via super chat do
you believe that this Iran thing is a
bigger deal than when Kalamazoo College
allowed transgender wrestling that is an
extraordinarily prescient question
because as huge as this is transgender
wrestling is is just an issue of
foremost importance absolutely Dave
Rubin thank you for the super chat on
the $5 I appreciate that
Joe Raider says via super chat I read on
Twitter that Iran contacted the u.s. via
proxies to warn that they would need to
bomb bases to save face for the
assassination response so US personnel
were evacuated very well maybe Joe
please send a source if you have that
Ave Caesar 2112 says thanks for ripping
me out of Jordan Peterson's sphere of
influence my pleasure my friend I'm glad
to be of service of course thanks to
Terry bobbins
subscribing with twitch Prime as well if
you are just joining us we have seen a
response a military response from Iran
bombing two US bases in Iraq we have not
heard anything from Donald Trump on
Twitter for seven hours and I will
refresh to confirm that and indeed that
remains the case
we are watching to see what happens next
this is extraordinarily scary this
reminds me of the similar it feels like
it must have been 9:10 p.m. as well back
in 2003 when it was announced that
George W Bush started the
extraordinarily misguided arguably
illegal and completely disgusting war in
Iraq and it is feeling much the same
with an even more erratic person and
remember that this is because of
impeachment this is because Donald Trump
is desperate to get himself reelected
and I whether it will work or not I
don't know
often military conflicts are good for
re-election but this is this is the
Trump era and I'm sort of struggling for
four words because this is so
extraordinarily disturbing Christian
birdie L Fernandez says do you think
Trump will be remembered like Bush on
the Iraq war as a failure and disaster I
hope that it is worse I hope that it is
worse Simon Paul says that the White
House has confirmed Donald Trump will
not be communicating with the people
tonight well that certainly that seems
to cover some kind of live address but
at any time he may be tweeting we don't
know let's take a listen to the coverage
here this is video from earlier the
United States felt the ball was in
Iran's court to use a cliche and they
were going to be one of the main
decision makers over how things would
transpire over the next few days but one
of my contacts who works within the
White House cautioned this evening that
the Iranians are extremely smart
and they're extremely strategic and
they're also extremely patient you know
there's a phrase in that part of the
world that we have watches but they have
time you know so they're extremely
patient I don't want to make light of
that but they're very smart that way and
my contact sense was that significant
retaliation by the Iranians might not
come until some future date it might not
be immediate mm-hmm and very interesting
well if that statement by secretary
Esper was meant to be an olive branch of
sorts it was certainly not taken as that
by the gist that I'm getting is that the
non-trump forces that be at the Pentagon
are trying to prevent an escalation and
if indeed the the the strategy from Iran
will be to wait before anything bigger
is done to see if Donald Trump further
escalates then maybe there is a chance
that Donald Trump will be talked out of
further escalation by people like Mark
Esper it is it's it's a question mark
and one way or another this is this is
going to be this is going to last some
time politically the question of whether
this becomes an extended military
conflict remains to be seen loko nico
says via super chat on youtube oil
taints everything in that region and
soaks it in blood people have been dying
for oil in the Gulf for more than a
century now tisha T says is it true that
Raytheon and oil stocks went up since
last week it is true okay Joe Rader now
is sending me a link to a tweet now full
warning you know I don't know for sure
what what how much this can be trusted
this is being repeated by a lot of Miss
Middle East journalists Taron told
Washington DC through proxies that it
will bomb US bases in Iraq to save face
and claim it as a response for killing
Soleimani that's why the USA emptied its
bases hours before the attacks
zero casualties that that may well be
and hopefully we will ultimately find
out more more about that V says just a
reminder if there is a draft you can
file as a conscientious conscientious
objector to avoid being drafted probably
won't be one but just in case and Safari
J says we nation-build like China does
communism meaning in name only shouldn't
we have left massive troops in Iraq to
rebuild and stabilize we had massive
troops in Iraq for a very long time John
McLane says Trump manipulating his
followers to believing Hillary was a war
hawk while he wasn't now he bombs Iran
three years later and his supporters go
along with it it is an amazing
accomplishment it has been gaslighting
for four years at this point it is
should not come as a surprise to anybody
that that is that Donald Trump has done
not only the opposite of what he said he
would do but the thing he said Hillary
Clinton would do if you're just joining
us we are all together trying to figure
out whether whether we are going to war
with Iran tonight as you may know Donald
Trump ordered the assassination of the
Iranian codes leader Kasim soleimani in
response Iran has bombed two US bases in
Iraq this may be the start of a bigger
escalation and the start of the Iran war
as it may one day come to be known this
may be merely Iran doing something in
order to save face as some are claiming
with no further plans for escalation we
have not seen any tweets from Donald
Trump
for seven hours the White House has said
that Donald Trump will not be addressing
the nation tonight in any case but we
may of course at any point hear from him
via Twitter we are also following a live
blog from Reuters and I am not seen
seeing anything okay this one's pinned
so we actually have an update from six
minutes ago footage broadcast on Iranian
TV shows a number of missiles fired into
the sky as well as explosions from
missiles believed to be landing at
I mean al Asad airbase in Iraq which
hosts US forces let's take a look
all right I think we get a sense of that
report from a few minutes prior
we know that markets are reacting in a
concerned way to what is going on a
picture of the White House after the
attacks FAA 2 prohibits u.s. civil
operators from airspace over Iraq Iran
Persian Gulf and the Gulf of Oman I
actually want to take a look at that let
me see if I can find flightradar24 I
would be interested in looking at that
let me see if I can find a new window
here I'm curious to see what's going on
with routing in the Middle East right
now let's see what we can find and so
I'm able to read that again I'm actually
interested in that wait a second where
was it 855 over Iraq Iran the Persian
Gulf and the Gulf of Oman yeah so
nothing particularly notable happening
yet it seems like with air traffic in
terms of large disruptions but all of
the normal things that we see and expect
in these situations seem to be happening
let's take a look this seems like an
actual live report now that these two
missiles landed north of the US
consulate away from the US military
presence here we haven't heard of any
casualties we had a team that went by
the consulate to see if the if there was
any action there it seemed fairly calm
from what we could see so right now
there's just a lot of anticipation of is
this over or is there gonna be another
round that's going to be incoming right
now really no one knows had security
there been beefed up were these attacks
anticipated at all
you know we've heard statements from the
Iranian government we heard them from
Shia militias here in Iraq that they're
going to retaliate they're gonna
retaliate with vengeance Americans were
anticipating this but what's interesting
is a few days ago we heard from one of
the Iraqi militias cathay as below they
warned Iraqi soldiers around these bases
to stay a kilometer way so a little over
a mile away from the US military
presence so most of this we we already
know please make sure if you're watching
on youtube as nearly 10,000 of you are
to hit that subscribe button it's a
quick easy free thing you can do just to
support the streams and I really
appreciate folks joining me on what is
potentially a historic and disgustingly
horrible evening if you are over on
Twitch please consider yourself invited
to renew or start a twitch Prime
subscription to the David Pakman show
twitch channel I appreciate everybody
who signed up so far including most
recently Terry bobbins who subscribed
with twitch prime if you have questions
or comments on youtube please send them
in via super chat and I will continue
answering as far as moderators we have
like 12 moderators on Twitch and 12
moderators on YouTube I don't know how
many of you guys are here but please
there is a lot of anti-semitism some
directed against me there is a lot of
crazy BS happening in the chat so help
me out whoever whoever can help me out
if we have monitored moderators on
either please please do I would
appreciate that very much
Shane babaca babka of course one of my
three Freight favorite desserts
along with flan actually I have more
than I have a lot of favorite desserts
but babka is up there Shane babka says
now Trump is going to do what
Republicans do best and cry victim
we're so effed just remember the rich
will cheer on any war even a nuclear war
because they will survive it while we
the poor will not there is an over class
no question that does very well
that does very very well in military
conflict a lot of people get very very
rich let me say thanks to some folks who
just signed up at join pakman.com kyle
beverage is a new member will Collins is
a new member
Taylor McLean thank you so much will
Collins getting two memberships I don't
know if will actually meant to do that
but we'll count them both for now if
that was an error well we'll deal with
that later will but I appreciate your
support very much at join pakman.com I
missed a few other super chats mister
CBF 21 says will a war with Iran be
worse than Vietnam the propaganda that
is possible today because of Fox News
and all of these other right-wing media
outlets is far more pervasive than
anything that was around during the
Vietnam era so in that way the
disinformation campaigns will be will be
absolutely malignant and virus like in
some way so in some way it will be it
will be extremely it will be worse in
terms of deaths I mean we don't even
know if this is actually building to
being a war or if this is going to be it
we just don't know I have no idea okay
I'm getting noticed that Nancy Pelosi
tweeted let's see what is happening with
Nancy Pelosi and see what she said as
she tweeted two hours ago closely
monitoring the situation following
bombings targeting US troops in Iraq we
must ensure the safety of our service
members including angling need ending
needless provocations from the
administration and demanding that Iran
is cease its violence America and world
cannot afford war okay that that was a
couple of hours ago and I don't know
whether we are going to hear from her
again
thanks to twitch Scott f200 for
subscribing with twitch prime thanks to
Kayla Rin and Dre Lowe as well as amber
roses for subscribing with twitch prime
Anthony baloney or Bologna jack 17
thanks so much to all you guys as well
as serrated riot very very much
appreciate the support
super chats on youtube or
coming in fast and furious and why
wouldn't they with 86 people
8600 people on the livestream
okay these are scrolling by Andrew Dwyer
says have you read management of
savagery by max Blumenthal what are your
thoughts it seems relevant I have not
read it could not comment
Daniel Rivera what percentage of
Americans do you think would oppose a US
Iran war my instinct is that it would be
a very high percentage of Americans that
would oppose an Iran war let's do this
again we did this about a half hour ago
is there anybody watching this right now
on either YouTube or twitch that is in
favor of going to war with Iran let me
know in the chat on either last time it
there were like two people and it seemed
like they were trolling and I'll say
more if you are in favor of going to war
with Iran tell me why you are in favor
of it and if you say something like
let's kick their ass I'm gonna assume
that you're trolling so somebody is is
there anybody who can give me a good
reason for this only if we get our asses
kicked right yeah it seems
overwhelmingly the answer is no I get
that these are you know very biased
samples of my audience but there's
usually right-wingers watching my my
videos let's take a listen to this
latest report from the White House with
the Vice President but so far we have
not heard from the President himself
about these Iranian attacks because on
the one hand of course it would take
longer than just a matter of hours for
him to decide his next move with his
team and then announced don't be so sure
the country in the world but on the
other hand you know they were
anticipating this officials came out
today and said they knew that Iran was
probably going to retaliate in some way
or another and that the US would be
ready to respond appropriately president
Trump did say earlier today that if Iran
does anything that they shouldn't be
doing they're going to be some
during the consequences and very
strongly of course first exactly he
means right now is the answer that
everybody is waiting for because as
Democrats already point out on Capitol
Hill that will determine what happens
next in Tehran and whether this will
continue to escalate and how serious it
could become but certainly already these
consequences are potentially dire and
congressional leaders are publicly
voicing their concerns about what this
means
as for the president again we are
closely monitoring his Twitter feed
because often that's how he announces
dramatic foreign policy announcements
dramatic moves that he plans to make
nothing at all Tania so I think that's a
good indication that they are very
carefully calculating what happens next
absolutely it is it is anytime they so
we're getting into the point of the
night now where they are just sort of
like repeating the same 90 second video
over and over again because not much new
is happening I I would not a suit the
one thing I disagree with in that report
is I would not assume that it's going to
take Donald Trump a very long time to
figure out what to do he is the type of
guy that will very quickly decide what
to do and do something extremely erratic
and it will be terrible for everybody
number theory 34:34 asks via super chat
does this mean World War three we don't
know yet we hope not but we will see
liquid ice 55 has subscribed for four
months in a row with twitch Prime and
says David mess up your hair like last
stream to complement the stressful
situation you know I can't do that
because the reason I did that last
stream is I had not yet showered and I
have showered today and the sigh I just
can't do that
I'm unfortunately unable to oblige so de
bois de subscribe for two months and
says if the United States does retaliate
what do you think the likelihood that
Iran allies would join the fight we will
address that tomorrow and I think it is
certainly more than a nonzero chance
Anders Olofsson
has subscribed with twitch prime aisle
maokai has subscribed with twitch Prime
as has bladdy meow very much appreciate
the support tisha asks via super chat is
it true that Pelosi recently voted to
give Trump an extra eighty billion
dollars for war I don't know if the
number was eighty billion but she did
she did Jordan Baldwin why did Nancy
Pelosi move the War Powers vote to next
week don't did not know that she did a
lot of people are saying to check out
Ollie Aroo Z's tweets so let's do that
ollie our Uzi let's take a look at what
alia rusy is tweeting okay this is key
right now if America does not respond to
these attacks this may be over for now
if America attacks it will escalate okay
yeah I mean that that seems perfectly
reasonable the Iranian state media is
saying that the IRGC has readied all of
its underground missile depots they are
reporting that they are ful fully battle
ready how this unfolds depends on the US
response Iraqi Shia militias under
Iran's patronage are saying that they
have launched their operations against
the US presence in Iraq Iranian state
media says none of their ballistic
missiles were intercepted they all hit
targets Iran is saying that there is if
there is no retaliation from America
they will stop attacking if America
attacks their response will be crushing
and widespread this is what Donald Trump
is now sitting around discussing with
his generals who he of course said he
would he would trust and take very
seriously flow tog says David do you see
a do you foresee any of the presidential
candidates supporting war with Iran I
don't I don't the J raid says I am a
veteran combat combat infantryman and I
will be happy to defend the pro-war Hawk
position logically well defended I am
not seeing any logical defense so far
yeah let me say thanks to Jeff Solomon
who just signed up for a membership at
join pakman.com as well as Alex Davis
thanks to both of you guys really
appreciate your support
join pakman.com
oh did we just freeze did I just freeze
momentarily my entire system just froze
that was really weird very strange I did
freeze not very weird all good now
people are saying very good appreciate
that Mohamed Pope says we've known for
years that the establishment wants war
with Iran regardless of their actions
how can they get away with this the same
way they got away with the Iraq war
number two the same way they got away
with a rock war number one the same way
they got away with Vietnam and on and on
Brendan Haslett says wow I've been
tripping on mushrooms and I'm just
finding out about this what can Bernie
Sanders do at this point if he were to
win in 2020 you know you you seem to be
tripping balls so I'm just gonna let you
do your thing my friend I don't know how
much I can say about your question Raina
a Kree says what is Hezbollah why attack
Dubai and hothea who attacked Dubai I'm
not sure I know exactly what you're
referring to let's listen to this report
from the Pentagon now take a look at
some more information on what defense
secretary asper was doing doing this
afternoon and this evening
both he and general Milley the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff were here
in the Pentagon when the attack occurred
and then went to the White House to
debrief the President and then came back
and they have had a number of meetings
that the entire Joint Chiefs of Staff
met with the Secretary of Defense the
Secretary of Defense and other officials
in this building made calls to all of
the regional allies of those those would
be the Arab countries in the region and
to all the traditional NATO allies of
the US to give them a briefing on what
and and then of course there's the the
question that everybody wants an answer
to what will be the American response to
this attack and the answer to that was
I'm not going to forecast any response
so other than the whereabouts and the
actions of the Secretary of Defense and
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs this
background or from a defense official
did not really add anything to what we
knew all right David Martin at the
Pentagon thank you so much for that
update sure thing
let's bring back in Natalie brand on
Capitol Hill let's listen another minute
or two to this information on lawmaker
reaction Tonya reaction is beginning to
trickle in across the lawmakers still on
the capital and speaking before cameras
tonight so let me read you some of what
the House Foreign Affairs Committee
chairman eliot engel Democrat of New
York said he of course the first concern
is with US troops and prayers that there
were no casualties this is a very fluid
situation we don't know what lawmakers
know at this point but really he said
that we need to know more about a
strategy and there's a lot of concern
that this could spiral out of control
very very quickly this is something that
Democratic lawmakers on the hill have
been calling for all right nothing
particularly newsworthy there so let me
continue to see what's on folks minds as
they send in super chats and twitch
prime messages
Daniel Rivera says is there any way the
Iran relationship can be restored yes
but not by Donald Trump it will be up to
the next president
f-t says I wish they would send Trump
there to catch some missiles with his
big mouth interesting imagery for sure
okay I think that that is it as far as
super chats go let me say thanks to some
folks who have been sending messages
over on Twitter if you are watching on
twitch please make sure to follow we are
just a hair shy of 22,000 followers on
Twitch we are just a hair shy of 800,000
subscribers on YouTube and I invite you
to
your touch Prime subscription Kiko 73
says thank you David with their twitch
prime sub capitis has subscribed with
twitch Prime Luke eva has subscribed for
the second month in a row very much
appreciate that Minister just released a
Twitter message can someone tell me
which Minister so I can pull that
account up if somebody tells me I'm glad
to get that up on screen for us do we
know who that which Minister that is or
what the Twitter username is unclear
Iran foreign minister okay let's see if
we can fight I wish I knew their
username Iran foreign minister okay I
don't think that that's it J's Arif okay
got it
twelve minutes ago this is a statement
from Iran Iran took and conducted
proportionate measures in self defense
under article 51 of UN Charter targeting
base from which cowardly armed attack
against our citizens and senior
officials were launched we do not seek
escalation or war but we'll defend
ourselves against any aggression so
there's two ways to interpret this okay
there if we say that they are being
honest and upfront then this really
could be it
the other interpretation is they know
that Donald Trump will not be able to
resist a further escalation and so they
can do what they call a response and
then say this is it unless Trump does
more knowing that this is very likely to
trigger Donald Trump to do more so this
tells us very little about what is
likely to happen hopefully within the
next few hours or maybe early tomorrow
we will know from Donald Trump what his
plan is lady Loki says via super chat
broke also heard of Putin's travels
Trump performing on his behalf
manipulate markets and cryptocurrency
markets ayatollah power iraq expulsion
destroy democracies russian promise kept
there's a lot there my friend and i'm
not fully understanding all of it but i
appreciate the support very very much
david r says no david one more does
anyone really think this wouldn't happen
or be the last response from iran i have
a hard time imagining that donald trump
will do nothing trump has tweeted
someone is saying let's see what Donald
Trump has said ah all is well missiles
launched from Iran at two military bases
located in Iraq assessment of casualties
and damages taking place now so far so
good we have the most powerful and
well-equipped military anywhere in the
world by far I will be making a
statement tomorrow morning this is like
he woke up and had a nice email from his
long-lost aunt this does not seem like
Donald Trump
let's retweet this with a comment this
sounds a very little like Donald Trump
he sounds like he woke up on the right
side of the bed during vacation not like
a guy handling a potentially disastrous
military escalation that's a very
strange tweet it actually does sound
like Trump is sleeping Trump may already
be sleeping and someone else tweeted
this yeah that something's very very odd
about that tweet I'm having a hard time
believing that let me thank a few other
people I want to say thanks to Stephanie
Wagoner who'd signed up at join
pakman.com very much appreciate that
really appreciate the support 20 great
people have signed up tonight at join
pakman.com we are all trying to figure
out what is going on tonight and a lot
of questions coming in via super jab
DIY till I die says mainstream media is
really banging the drums here
military-industrial complex stocks are
going to skyrocket tomorrow Jimmy
Calhoun says David honestly this is only
about Trump there is no 3d chess
he's clearly unstable he knows war will
distract from impeachment remember when
he accused Obama of this type of thing I
absolutely do
Freddy Bernard knowing the president's
history of making irrational decisions
would it be reasonable to suggest that
Trump will respond with a counter-attack
on Iran if I had to bet I would bet that
Trump does attack what are we watching
here it looks like we've gone on to
something else I would bet that Donald
Trump does retaliate but only by a
slight majority I think it's 55/45 that
Trump retaliates given what we've seen
so far
Barda moose New Zealand says tax cuts
judges and now a new war but Trump is an
outsider am i right and Trump is
currently on his downer phase no
question about it
Jimmy tenpins says with his third month
in a row twitch prime sub David in your
opinion who of all the Democratic
candidates can most effectively deal
with a conflict in Iran I think all of
the frontrunners on the Democratic side
are question marks around foreign policy
Joe Biden has the most knowledge but has
the worst positions Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders the other two
frontrunners have better positions but I
find them lacking in knowledge and you
know I I don't really think anybody else
has a serious shot at this point in time
Brahe tea subscribed for six months on
twitch and says hey David what do you
think happens to Israel if the situation
escalates
maybe it's getting sucked up in the mess
that's a real threat for our ally
I think his rule is going to be okay I
think his rule is going to be okay in
all of this collapses says be a super
chat
as a Marine Corps veteran of nine years
service if Trump orders us to attack
Iranian cultural sites and civilians we
are required to disobey his unlawful
order fellow service members do your
duty an important message and I hope you
are right
Andy Rouge has just checked out Hannity
didn't know Oliver North was still a
credible commentator I suppose he does
know a lot about Iran I actually in my
notes for a story I'm doing tomorrow I
was writing about Oliver North and how
it's incredible that he is still
considered a serious person unbelievable
Sabrina asks hey David this is crazy
what do you think motivated the attack
well the assassination of Kasim
soleimani motivated this attack which is
just a direct response that's that's
that that's what it is that's what we're
dealing with here
Terry Fuld says McConnell just released
the Trump trial plan no witnesses were
they waiting for this distraction would
not be surprised whatsoever would not be
surprised whatsoever Terry I will review
that and maybe comment on that tomorrow
we will see let's see we are starting to
see we are seeing both criticisms of
Israeli foreign policy in the chat which
is fine but we are also starting to see
anti-semitism which is not okay and
we're not going to allow the
anti-semitism that that I promise you my
friends we are not going to allow it
folks asking what is this right here
what is this this is website memberships
okay if you look above see where it says
join pakman.com to become a member
save 66% with coupon 2020 now that is
what moves the bar so like the last
person to sign up with Stephanie Wagoner
and it went from 19 to 20 and yeah
that's so I recommend people do that why
not right it's a it's a beautiful thing
let's see if Donald Trump has sent any
follow-up tweets it seems pretty safe to
say that this is likely to be the only
tweet we see from him tonight let's see
if there are any interesting responses
decapitated the Iraqi army so now Iran
is just waiting there just waiting and
at some point there's no question as
sure as you're sitting here unless
something else happens first like
somebody wanting to get elected and the
only way he's gonna do it is to start a
war with Iran because I tell you what if
Iran is in negotiating now they gotta be
crazy because they are sitting and I
said this the other day they are sitting
on hot timber they are really crazy if
they're not negotiating and by the way
they do in my opinion wanna negotiate
but we may have somebody that wants to
have war because he doesn't want to
accept a negotiation which turn out to
be much stronger than war and you could
make a much better deal than war but it
may be good politics
I predict there's a very good chance
that we'll end up in a war with Iran
because I think it's politically
possibly a positive for Obama even
though it's not a good thing for our
country very very relevant today a whole
bunch of super chats coming in that I
want to get to Lars Morton who says have
a look at dr. Saeed Jalili at Twitter a
representative of the Iranian government
posted a mirror of trumps tweet after
the attacks what has come of this world
let's take a look yes so I'm this is not
I'm not really able to read this is the
only thing so I think we're gonna go
back to Trump's Trump's Twitter octo s--
alias says Washington Examiner says Iran
says if the u.s. responds they will
strike Dubai Haifa [ __ ] will get very
real then [ __ ] will get very very real
then no pity nope says sounds like Trump
was talked out of an aggressive response
and now he has to act as if nothing bad
has happened to not seem weak when he
backs down that ik that may be exactly
what's going on when he says all is well
that you may be exactly right a retro
path act says LP don't Acadia more
reliable than Anna's tech idea I I don't
know LP don't occur
yeah and I've only been to Anna's once
so I unfortunately am unable to say
casual Thursday says hey David would you
consider the assassination of sulemani
an impeachable offense I I you know in a
vacuum I would in modern American
politics I would not David are says
David my younger brother is playing
switch in the next room and says the
recent attack probably won't change
anyone's opinion on Trump one way or the
other he's voting for primary by the way
for Bernie in the primary yeah I bet
there's a very good chance that this
doesn't do anything one way or the other
in terms of trumps reelection I think
that's a perfectly reasonable
possibility Sabrina says I meant to ask
what motivated the attack on general
Soleimani in the first place the things
I don't know after taking a break from
US news oh well the Trump administration
is claiming both that the attack on
soleimani was because of he posed an
imminent threat and because of past
things that he did they're kind of
giving conflicting explanations and
we'll cover that on the show tomorrow I
already have copious notes about it
Kyle knitter says I appreciate all that
you do Kyle kolinsky wrong channel my
friend this is the this is the David
Pakman show I appreciate that though if
you're just joining us we're trying to
figure out if we are going to war with
Iran if you're just joining us over on
YouTube please absolutely destroy that
subscribe button we are closing in on
800,000 subscribers and I would really
appreciate if you hit subscribe it's
free much like us banning people is free
it costs us nothing hitting subscribe is
free and I would appreciate that if
you're watching over on Twitch please do
follow I'm only 23 followers away from
22,000 on Twitch and I would appreciate
folks getting us closer to that and to
the extent that these platforms continue
to be good for us we will keep streaming
on them very very much appreciated
welcome to John Baker and Sarah Clark
who signed up at join pakman.com really
appreciate your support and that is 22
new members this evening very much
appreciated thank you so much
super chats starting to flow in very
very rapidly hard [ __ ] bataya
says you think if there's a lot of
casualties there will be more pressure
to respond I think there will be no
casualties from what Iran has done it
seems to have been the evacuations
seemed to have taken place I would be
surprised if there were casualties
crispr all says you've taught at BC and
you've never had oh la lon Bellona I
thought you'd bet on I thought maybe it
was a joke as I'm Argentinian I have
been to El Belen but I don't remember
when or anything about it I wish I did
Trevor Warfield says we wouldn't be in
this mess if Trump hadn't backed out of
the Iran nuclear deal yes that's true
that is absolutely true
a retro pathetic says what's the best
place to get gelato is in Boston I don't
think I've ever gotten gelato in Boston
so I don't know a retro yes I I couldn't
really tell you thanks to son Deaver for
subscribing with twitch prime thanks to
Sam Zeldin for subscribing for six
months on twitch thanks to fun crusher
as well I love seeing that our moderator
Daniel is banning people on YouTube
because people are being absolutely
toxic thank you very much Daniel is on
fire the ban hammer is free and we will
not hesitate to use it
Tony Calderon has subscribed at join
pakman.com as has Tucker Jones thanks to
both of you guys very much appreciate it
so it seems in all likelihood that we
are not going to hear from Donald Trump
again tonight based on what he said I
don't believe that we are going to be
seeing a retaliatory attack tonight so
on that note I am going to cut this very
unexpected last minute stream and we
will have a full show and potentially
more streams tomorrow so thanks to
joining me last minute here that does it
for today I would not expect more action
tonight